99 of the time
you're showing up there and it's fun
yeah it's like you're you're getting
it's a wonderful rally back and forth in
these scenes and our show was like
silly
but then heartfelt at the same time but
then had like badass action but then
super goofy was it the first time you
ever had to kiss a woman was on lucifer
i mean on on tv
she's always dropping those bombs
those rosen bombs
[Laughter]
but it wasn't the first time in real
life i can't
in real life in real life uh
was it my first time on tv no i don't
think on tv probably in spartacus you
probably did something no i didn't no i
i'm just wondering if it was like you
know it's the first time you do
something it's we you know i i've had to
kiss a man before it's never been weird
of course it was actually i did in
college
we were playing spin the bottle
and uh
we guys had to kiss guys if girls kiss
girls that was just the rule so i was
like fine i think it's weird i want to
see girls kiss girls so let's go and
then they spun the bottle on me and i
had to kiss
you know matthew semrick and i was like
he had great lips i wasn't into it
matthew simmering the great lips we
kissed each other i was like hey man
your soft kisser and now i know why you
get all the hotties
you know uh i had to kiss rorke kissed
him
anyway back to you uh
yeah i don't no but it was not weird for
me it wasn't weird you kind of get used
to it where you're like oh no i love
this person
no yeah but also it's like it's the work
you know i mean that's the that's the
thing about
actors my husband's an actor too and
you know we gotta kiss other people you
just gotta get used to it do you ever go
home and go god it was really great
kissing that guy
why the [ __ ] would i do that i know how
rude be
but you know what it's i'll tell you
what there is something to be said about
like people go people always the
response from actors that i've talked to
is like it's a job man it's just a job
i'm just going through i've seen people
not
have it be more than a job like i see
i've seen people have things develop you
know it is a job you just have to
like
you have to be truthful
and professional and professional yes
but i'm just saying like those days
where i didn't kiss kristen kruek
on smallville
uh
i'm not saying those were
maybe they were worse days
than the days where i actually had to
kiss her it wasn't a bad thing that i
had to kiss her
to chris i was professionally no she
knows i always joke about it but i'm
like you know it doesn't suck
you know all i care is fresh breath man
that's my thing oh that's me too if you
have a bad breath you'll come out listen
i will literally have a conv a sidebar
conversation with your makeup artist and
i'll be like i'm excuse me can you just
make sure that there's mints in there
yeah i think they had a [ __ ] sandwich
before i'm like can you please and i i
i've been known to ask people like hey
so we have kissing scene would you mind
just like brushing your teeth before
flossing flossing
turpentine whatever you do yeah you know
that's what i'm talking about yeah just
take it down the throat yeah there's not
nothing worse when you have a sex scene
and you're just like oh boy
and people okay they don't get it so i
had this all right so so on spartacus
this actor
who
he would go and run around the [ __ ]
ludus like
i gotta get my jet gotta get my muscles
you know up he'd run around nude no like
run around the ludus
right and i'm like
dude is sweating
smelling smelling
and i've lit i'm like can you someone
get the axe body spray or
whatever musk like what that's
unprofessional so i'm proficient
like so i'm perfect and like sweet and
then you've got it like i was so i'm
with you yeah please
you